in this time the most precious substance
in the universe is the spice melange the
spice extends life
the spice expands consciousness
whatever that timer which is teacher you
don't hear spicy step-sibling crushes
teacher-student relationships I'm a
teacher and you're my student we all
know it's not incest anyway if you shout
no chromo like yeah sure why not my
other sister won't get with me Sika
relationship of all time what's max
find out on the next episode of two
girls one brother it's been like 200
chapters now I don't know where this can
go
not to Andrew he seem like they have a
pretty strong relationship right now so
what the hell was going to happen why
why are you doing this rui so [ __ ]
stupid know what I was team he know or
Rui but now I've made my choice
team Hina all the way that's right
here's the new best girl everyone Koch
BAE look at this girl she has a chance
when she's competing with a completely
normal non blood-related non sibling
relationship yeah yeah haha suck a dick
suck a dick suck God dead you know I
just feel kind of bad oh boy and he
sounds back in the game baby
holy [ __ ] is this happening Lee are they
actually are they doing an incest
ornament talk no don't don't do this no
no why why would you do this to me you
just go back in the game you know just
go back in the game
we still have hope right there's still
plenty of room to turn this around its
domestic your friend it's not over yet
it's okay you know don't be sad it's
gonna be okay
okay we're not in the best position now
but maybe wait what what ah [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] okay this is this is a pretty
big blow but there might be this is it I
guess we're in the endgame now there's
literally no turning back from this
she's having a baby they've told their
parents they're getting married
everyone's accepted it
Tina's accepted it there's no coming
back from this congratulations team Rui
you won
wait what is this what is going on we're
not just gonna end it there look we've
got the result now what more could
possibly happen what what why are you
doing this
domestic girlfriend what doing this just
end it already
take away my suffering I've already
accepted the result wait wait what are
you doing you couldn't be done
don't tell me you're doing this right
now no no no Rui Rui what are you doing
you're pregnant you're getting married
this is the biggest throw in the history
of best girl why would you do that oh
god they're babies a kid now it's been
five years and you still on this [ __ ]
what is this what is happening that's no
[ __ ] way there's no [ __ ] way the
coma straps for coma strats here coming
in clutch with the 360 no scope 420 coma
strats it's a never-before-seen
technique it was like 7 105 minutes left
in the game but she lost to a [ __ ]
vegetable vegetable I can't like I gone
it's over it's [ __ ] over we found
this we found the summit to mess the
conference the greatest ever created
there is not enough milk in the world to
wash away these spice levels such a girl
can't sup Yan you absolute mad last we
have reached being trash and we will
never reach this pointed out stop don't
no Kimmy needed
[Music]
so how'd your parents meet oh you know
my mummy who's also my step-aunt adds me
with my daddy he was also my step uncle
but they decided not to get married
because my dad step uncle was still in
love with my step aunt is also my actual
aunt so I never knew as a kid cuz she
was in a coma since I was born so one
day my dad step on Cooper proces to my
own step heart even though she's still
in a coma and for some reason that's
fine with my mum step ons
so she wakes up because I put the ring
my dad step uncle gave to my aunt's
death on when they were having a love
affair while being teacher and students
in high school and also step siblings
dad stepped on courgettes married to my
aunt step aunt and find my mum step
aren't my grandma step grandma and my
grandfather step and say my aunt step on
becomes my aunt step on who's also my
step that's all my parents met
so someone used my email and pretended
to be me and emailed studio wits okay
okay I got the email here actually
[Music]